สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้มาเจอ
กันใน comprehensible  Thai นะคะอื
comprehensible  Thai นะคะก็วันนี้นะคะ
วันที่เนาะวันที่
มย
ใช่โอเควันที่วันที่เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าวัน
นี้ันนี้วันวันอะไรก่อนมั้ยวันอะไรได้อื
ได้ค่ะวันนี้วันพุธนะคะวันพุธอื
โอเควัน
พุธวันที่เท่าไหร่
ค่ะวันที่
18 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มกราคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะคุณูฟ้าปีพ.ศ 25  5
66 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  23 นะคะ 20
20  23 กี่โมงแล้วคะครู
ฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 14 น 19 นค่ะ
หืม 14  199 นีอืมใช่แล้วค่ะ 14  199 น
แล้วครูเรียงกินข้าวหรือยังกินข้าวเรียบ
ร้อยแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังู
ฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะอิ่มมากอ๋อเหรอครูฟ้าไป
กินอะไรมา
คะวันนี้ครูพ้ากินอาหารเกาหลีค่ะว้าว
อาหารเกาหลีชื่ออะไรอ่ะกินขนอกใช่มั้ย
เอ่อครูฟ้าไม่ออกไปข้างนอกเลยค่ะครูเรียม
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะมีแอปพลิเคชั่นนะ
คะ
Grab  Food  grb
Food นี่คะะก็เลยสั่งในโทรศัพท์อาหาร
เกาหลีเห็นมั้ยอุยน่ากินจังเลยใช่นะคะก็
เลยสั่งในแอปพลิเคชั่น
Grab  Food อืแล้วก็จะมีคนขี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์เอาอาหารมาให้ครูฟ้าที่บ้านนะ
คะูก็นอนรออาหารอ๋อืมเห็นสราคาในราคาใน
อะไรนะแกปฟูดของูฟ้าเออมันมีแบบราคา
159 แบบเนี้ย 89 อะไรอย่างเงี้ยออ 89
ใช่ทำไมเ้าถึงแบบไม่แบบ
120  130 เออ 160 ก็ได้
จะแบบ 90 ก็ได้จริงคือมันมันคิดยากนะอะไร
ที่มันเป็นเลข 9 ถ้ามันเป็น 120 บาท 160
บาท 90 บาทมันโอเคใช่มั้ยครูเรียมเวลาบวก
ๆบบวแล้วเนี่ยก็โอเคใช่แต่คนไทยค่ะทำไม
ริมก็คิดอยู่เวลาที่เรียนแบบคิด
อ่อคิดเลขแล้วก็แบบ 1 แล้ว
129  +
159  +  89 เอ๊มันมันเท่ากับเท่าไหร่มัน
เท่ากับเท่าไหร่ใช่มครูฟ้าเท่ากับเท่า
ไหร่ใช่คิดยากเหมือนกันนะยากหรอเราก็
เรียนมาแล้ว
นะใช่ค่ะเราก็เรียนมาแล้วแต่
ว่าเราเรียนอะไรมาคะครูเรียมเราเรียนวิชา
คณิตศาสตร์
วิชาคณิตศาสตร์ใช่มยครูฟ้ากับครูเรียมครู
ฟ้ากับครูเรียมผิดคนครูฟ้ากับครูเรียมนะ
คะเรียนใช่มั้ยคะมีหนังสือแล้วก็เรียนๆๆ
เรียนวิชาคณิตศาสตร์ตั้งแต่เด็กๆใช่มยใช่
วิชาคณิตนะคะนักเรียนบวกลบคูณหานะคะใช่
หรือว่าพาย r  ^  2  statistic มันมันมัน
เป็นคณิตศาสตร์มั้ยโอ้ปวด
หัวลูฟ้าเรียมจำได้แค่แบบบวกลบคูณหารแค่
นี้พอพอพาย r นี่แบบออปวดหัวปวดพาย r นะ
คะเอ่อเรียนอะไร Square  Root โอ๊ยปวดหัว
สรูทแคลคูลัส
ไม่ไม่ได้ครูฟ้าที่พูดมาครูฟ้าจำไม่ได้
เลยนะคะ
เอ๊ตอนเด็กๆเรียมก็คิดว่าเรียมเรียนในโรง
เรียนเ่ะครูฟ้าก็เรียนในโรงเรียนเรียน
คณิตศาสตร์เด็กๆเนี่ยเรียนตั้งแต่อนุบาล
มั้ยอนุบาลเรียนคณิตศาสตร์มั้ยใช่เรียนนะ
คะอนุบาลอนุบาลของคนไทยก็คืออายุ
ไร 5  5 ขวบ 5 ขวบเออ 4 ขวบ 5 ขวบ 6 ขวบ
นะคะตอนเด็กๆเราก็เรียนนะครูเรียมอืครู
ฟ้าน่าจะเรียนแบบอ่าในโทรศัพท์ของครูฟ้า
มีหมีเท่าไหร่ 1  2  3  4  5 มีหมี 5 ตัว
เนี่ยน่าจะเรียนแบบนี้นะคะตอนเด็กๆอืใช่
เรียมก็จำได้ว่าออตอนเด็กๆครูก็จะให้ดู
รูป
แอปเปิ้ลอื
แอปเปิลบวก
แอปเปิลอเหมือนแอปเปิ้ลมั้ย
เนี่ยแล้วก็เท่ากับเท่าไหร่เหม่ากับเท่า
ไหร่ใช่ใช่แล้วก็แบบเท่ากับ 2  1  2 อ๋อ
เท่ากับ 2 อหรือว่าเค้าจะมีกรอบมาให้มี
กรอบมาให้แล้วก็มีรูปข้างในอื้อหือส้ม
ส้มแล้วก็ให้เราตอบว่ามีส้มกี่ลูกอืมใช่
ค่ะมีส้มทั้งหมดกี่ลูก 5
ลูก 6 ลูกอะไรอย่างเงี้ยอันนี้คือตอนเด็ก
ๆ
เรียน 1  2  3  4
5 อันนี้ตอนเด็กๆเรียนพอเวลาโตขึ้นมาก็
แบบ
เฮ้ยส้มเอาให้ครูฟ้าอ้าวเริ่มะเริ่มแบบ
ตอนแรกตอนแรกเราเรียนมีแค่บวกใช่มั้ยมี
แค่บวกค่ะ 1  2  3  4  5 โอเคสบาย
[เพลง]
บสักพักนึงก็จะ
เริ่มเริ่มแบ่งให้คน
อื่นแบ่งให้คนอื่นยังไงครูเรียมเริ่มแบ่ง
ให้คนอื่นเา้าก็จะถามว่ามีส้มอยู่ 5
ลูกเอาให้ครูฟ้าไป 2 ลูกจะเหลือเท่าไหร่
อ่าให้ครูฟ้า 1  2 เหลือ 3 ลูกเหลือ 3
ลูกอใช่แบบนี้เราก็แบบเริ่มเรียนเกี่ยว
กับลบใช่มั้ยคะอลบ 5  -  2  =  3 แบบนี้
อืเแต่ว่าครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเรียมอยากรู้จังเลย
ว่าเวลาที่เราโตขึ้นมาเนี่ย
คณิตศาสตร์ที่เราใช้อ่ะเราเอาไปใช้อะไร
บ้างคณิตศาสตร์ที่เราเรียนใช่ไหมอที่เรา
เรียนตั้งแต่อายุ 5 ขวบเรียนียจนถึงอายุ
20  21  22 ปีเนี่ยโหเรียนมา 10 กว่าปี
เลยนะคะเราต้องเรียนคณิต 10 กว่าปีใช่
แล้วเราเอาคณิตไปทำอะไรใช่ที่เรียมคิดได้
นะเวลาเราซื้อขายของเวลาเราซื้อ
ของอืแบบไปที่ตลาดใช่มั้ยไปเจอแม่ค้าไป
ซื้ออะไรดีไปซื้อ
สตอเบอร์รี่
อืก็ถามแม่คะสตรอเบอร์รี่ขายยังไงคะแม่
ค้าอืสตรอเบอร์รี่กิโลละขายเป็นกิโลกกิโล
ละ
กิโลละ 150 บาทค่ะอุ๊ยแพงนะแพงใช่มั้ยครู
ปาคิดว่าแพงกิโลละ 150 บาทค่ะใช่
สตรอเบอร์รี่นะคะอะไิมก็เลยคิดออกเลยว่า
แบบแม่ค้าก็แบบ
เอ่อ 3 กิโลละ 150  3 ก 400 ได้มั้ยคะอ 3
ก 400 ได้มั้ยคณิศาสตร์มั้ยสบาเป็นคณิต
เหมือนกันค่ะอะไรที่เกี่ยวกับการคิดใช่มย
ตัวเลข 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9 มันคือ
คณิตนะคะคณิตศาสตร์อืมใช่เราเอา
คณิตศาสตร์เนี่ยไปใช้ในการซื้อของเป็น
สิ่งที่ใช้บ่อยใช่มั้ยภูเเรียมใช่ซื้อของ
ขายของนะคะทุกวันนะคิดว่าทุกวันอืใช่ทุก
วันเลยนะคะเวลาที่เราแบบเหมือนแบบไป
ซุเปอร์มาเก็ตเราก็ดูแบบเออวันนี้จะแบบ
ซื้อได้กี่บาทนะแล้วเรียมก็เอาโทรศัพ์กี่
บาทใช่มีเงิน 1,000 บาทก็แบบโอเคเดี๋ยว
เอากระดาษทิชชู่ใส่ในตะกร้าแล้วก็โอเค 200
แล้วก็บวก 200 อืมบวกๆเอจริงๆเราถ้าเรา
เรียนคณิตศาสตร์มาใช่มั้ยคะเรียนๆๆเราก็
คิด
ได้เลยคิดเร็วๆใช่มย 200  +  20  +  80  +
300 เราก็จะบวกบๆๆแล้วก็คิดได้
อือืแต่มันไม่ได้มีแค่บวกอย่างเดียวไงมัน
ยังมีอะไรอีกครับมันยังมีแบบมันยังมีบ
เวลาซื้อขายของเนาะบวกบวกแบบซื้อชิ้นที่ 1
20 บาทบวกชิ้นที่ 2  30 บาทบวกชิ้นที่ 3
40 บาทเท่ากับอ้าวงงเลยเท่าไหร่แล้ว
90 เท่ากับ 90 แล้วเวลาที่เราจ่ายเงิน
นี่ค่ะแบงค์
100 ให้ไป 100 บาทใช่ให้ไป 100 บาทคนขาย
ทอนมา 20
บาทโอเคมยโอเคโอเคนะคะเพราะว่าเราได้ก็
มันถูกมั้ยคะครู้าไม่ได้นะคะนัก
เรียนคนขายเนี่ยพรน
เงินผิดใช่มยเพราะว่าซื้อของราคา 90 บาท
เราให้เงินไป 100 บาทเราก็ต้องได้เงินทอน
10 บาทใช่ไหมใช่ธรรมดาเวลาที่ครูฟ้าซื้อ
ของแล้วก็ให้เงินไปเกินกว่าราคาของอ่ะอืๆ
ครูฟ้าได้แบบได้ได้ได้คิดมยว่าเอ้เ้าทอน
ถูกหรือ
ผิดไม่เคยคิดเลยจริงหรอมันก็มีจริงๆนะที่
แบบเอ่อจ่ายเงินค่ะแล้วก็รับตังค์ทอนมาก็
แบบเก็บใส่
กระเป๋าว่าเป็นคนประเภทนั้นนะคะ
ออแต่ว่าจริงๆมันก็ไม่โอเคใช่มยนักเรียน
เพราะว่าบางที
เราถ้าเราซื้อของด้วยเงินนิดหน่อยอ่ะมัน
ก็โอเคแหละแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนซื้อของ
เยอะไงเวลาซื้อของก็จะแบบ 1,000 บาทจ่าย
ไปแล้วพอได้เงินมาก็จะรีบเก็บใส่กระเป๋า
ครูฟ้าไม่ได้นับก่อนเลยว่าเอูฟ้าซื้อของ
ไปกี่บาทนะูฟ้าเป็นคนซื้อของไม่ค่อยคิดนะ
คะซื้อก็ซื้อๆๆแล้วก็จ่ายเงินไปแต่จริงๆ
มันต้องคิดก่อนนะว่าเราซื้อของอะไรบ้าง
เราซื้อของราคากี่บาทเราให้เงินไปกี่บาท
แล้วจะได้เงินทอนกี่บาทมันต้องคิดก่อนไง
อือืแต่ว่าครูฟ้าก็บอกว่าถ้าเกิดแบบจ่าย
เงินนิดนิดเดียวอ่ะก็โอเคก็แบบไม่ดูก็ได้
แต่ถ้าเกิดแบบจ่ายแบบเยอะๆหรือว่าแบบต้อง
เช็คพ่อค้าแม่ค้าต้องทอนเงินเยอะๆเราก็
ต้องแบบนับเงินดูอืใช่มั้คะก้องค่ะใช่ค่ะ
แล้วก็ริมก็เห็นนะบางคนที่แบบไปร้านอาหาร
แล้วเวลาที่สั่งข้าวเยอะๆแบบเอาผัดกะเพรา
ค่ะเอาข้าวผัดเอาปลาเผาเอาอะไรนะเอาต้มยำ
กุ้งแล้วเวลาที่แบบเรียกแบบกุ้งน้องคะมา
เช็คบินค่ะโอเคค่ะก็มีปากกาใช่มั้ยคะทุก
วันนี้เห็น iPad หรือว่าเห็นเครื่องคิด
เลข
อืแต่บางคนก็ไม่ใช้นะครูฟ้าเคยดูวิดีโอใน
tiktok หรือเปล่าไม่รู้ว่าครูเลียมเคย
เห็นมนะที่เา้าจะเป็นร้านอาหารน่ะอืเป็น
ไงคะ
พนักงานเป็นแคทเชียรหรือว่าเป็นใครก็ไม่
รู้อ่ะเวลาที่ลูกค้ากินข้าวเสร็จแล้วลูก
ค้าบอกว่าเช็คบินเก็จะเดินมาบอกผัดกะเพรา
โอเคผัดกะเพราต้มยำกุ้งผัดไทยแกงเขียว
หวานต้มข่าไก่แล้วก็จิ้มๆแล้วก็ทั้งหมด
ผัดกะเพรา 80 บาทต้มยำกุ้ง 120 ต้มข่าไก่
120 แล้วก็จะคิดๆๆๆๆแล้วก็พูดๆๆๆๆแล้วก็
บอกว่าบอกราคาอย่างเร็วอ๋อ 1,5  120 บาท
ใช่นะคะแบบเพราะว่าช็อกมากเลยว่าทำไมเค้า
เก่งคณิตศาสตร์มากๆคิดเก่งมากๆใช่ไหมอืม
ใช่เก่งแล้วเรียมก็เห็นนะเห็นที่แบบเวลา
ที่เราเรียกเช็คบินใช่มั้ยเช็คบินค่ะแล้ว
เคก็จะเดินมาแล้วก็แบบโอเคต้มยำกุ้ง 120
คิดเลขไงกดเครื่องคิดเลขคิดเลขคิดเลขแล้ว
ก็แบบอ๋อข้าวผัด 1 น้ำ
โค้กโอเคน้ำแข็ง 1 แข็งอะไรไม่ได้ดู
เครื่องคิดเลขนะทำแบบ
เเค้าจำได้ด้วยนะเต้องจำเมนู
มั้ยกดเร็วมากใช่ใช่แต่ว่าิมก็อยากได้แบบ
ที่มันเป็นบินน่ะแล้วเราก็มาดูอืแล้วก็ดู
ว่าออถูกมั้ยหรือว่าผิดอืๆนักเรียนทำแบบ
นั้นมั้ยส่วนใหญ่น่าจะทำแบบนั้นนะคิดว่า
คือการคิดเลขก็ยังมีอยู่ที่เราต้องใช้ใช่
มยแต่มันอาจจะสบายขึ้นแบบเราก็จะได้บินมา
แล้วเราก็รู้ว่าราคากี่บาทกี่บาทกี่กี่
บาทแล้วเก็จะคิดมาให้แล้วนะคะว่าราคากี่
บาทใช่อะไรอย่างเงี้ยแล้วเราก็ดูดดูได้
ด้วยว่าถ้าเกิดเป็นข้าวผัดเนี่ยเราสั่งมา
แค่ 1 จานแต่นายบินน่ะบอกว่าอ้าคูณคูณ 2
จานข้าวผัดใช่มั้ยคะ 2 จานเราก็แบบอืบิน
ผิดนะคะแบบเข้าผัดจานเดียวค่ะอืใช่อแบบ
นี้อนี้คือนี่ก็คือการที่เราเรียนคณิตมา
แล้วเราได้ใช้ใช่มยจริงๆมันถ้าเราคิดบ่อย
ๆเนี่ยเราก็จะได้ใช้
คณิตศาสตร์บ่อยๆนะคะมีประโยชน์มากนะคะนัก
เรียนเวลานักเรียนไปร้านข้าวนักเรียนลอง
คิดคิดๆแล้วก็เอ๊ะอันนี้ผิดเราก็จะบอกได้
ใช่มยใช่แล้วก็ได้ได้ใช้หารด้วยนะูฟ้าใช้
หารด้วยเหรอคะครูเลียมใชหารใชหเวลาไป
ไปกินข้าวกับเพื่อนไง
อือืเวลาไปกินข้าวกับเพื่อนเราต้องหาญ
เหรอคะก็มีมีบ้างที่แบบหาญกันนะเดี๋ยว
มื้อนี้หานกันอืก็แบบไปแบบกินข้าวไป 1,500
บาทแล้วก็ไป 3
คนไป 3 คน 500 บาทหาร 3 หาร
3 อืเดี๋ยวมื้อนี้หารกันนะก็แบบจ่ายค่า
ข้าวกินด้วยกัน 3 คนแฟร์ๆไงใช่มยใช่หรือ
ว่าครูฟ้าเลี้ยงก็ได้นะขอบคุณมากเลยอ๋อ
ค้าไม่ชอบคิดเลขนะคะไม่ชอบคิดไม่ชอบ
คณิตศาสตร์เก็บอกเดี๋ยวครูฟ้าเลี้งนะคะู
ไม่ชอบคิดอันนี้โอเคเหรอโอเคครูฟ้าก็บอก
ว่าเดี๋ยวมื้อนี้ครูฟ้าเลี้ยงไม่ต้องหาญ
เดี๋ยวมื้อถัดไปเดี๋ยวครูเรียมเลี้ยงอื
เออ
มื้อถัดไปเดี๋ยวเรียมให้กินแค่
500 ให้กินแค่ 500 ทำไมคุณเรียมมื้อถัด
ไปมันถูกนะคะอืมื้อถัดไปถูกมื้อนี้ 1,500
เดี๋ยวให้ครูฟ้าจ่ายคนเดียวอืเห็นมนี่คือ
การคิดเลขคนที่คิดคิดตัวเลขนะคะ 1  2  3
4  5 อะไรอย่างเงี้ยได้เร็วๆมันก็โอเค
ใช่มยอืใช่ๆหรือว่าลูกฟ้าเคยเห็นไมว่า
เวลาที่ร้านค้าเขาบอกว่าเหมือนอะไรนะ
เหมือนขายขายอะไรสักอย่างเยมเห็นเค้าขาย
น่าจะเป็นขายส้มนะอขายส้ม 1
กก 3  30 บาทแล้วพ่อค้าบอกว่า 3 กก 100  1
กก 30 บาท 3 ก
100  3 ถ้าเกิดเราไม่เก่งคณิตศาสตร์อ่ะ
ครู
ฟ้า
โอเค 1 ก 30 บาทอื 3 กก 100 บาทเ้าซื้อ 3
กกเลยถูกกว่าถูกเนาะเออถูกมั้ยถูกมั้ยคะ
นักเรียนราคาถูกมไม่ถูกส้ม 1 กก 1 ก 30
บาทนะคะแต่ว่า 3 กกลดราคาเหลือ 100 บาทออ
ใช่โอเคมยเราก็แบบ
ถ้าเกิดคนแบบคณิตศาสตร์เก่งๆก็แบบใช่หรอ
ถูกหรอก็จะรู้สึกแบบองงๆนิดนึงว่า 3 ก
100 มันมันราคาถูกหรอพ่อค้าลดราคาให้
แล้วหรออืจริงๆแล้วมันต้องกี่บาทมันต้อง
ลดราคาใช่มไม่ได้บวกราคานะคะใช่มันก็เป็น
แบบอะไรที่เราใช้อยู่ทุกวันนะส่วนใหญ่มัน
ก็จะเป็นเกี่ยวกับเรื่องเรื่องเวลาซื้อ
ขายของเนาแต่มันมีอย่างอื่นอีกนะครูฟ้ามี
อะไรอีกคะครูเรเกี่ยวกับเรื่องเวลา
ไงเวลาหรอเวลาก็เป็นคณิตศาสตร์ใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่เวลาก็เป็นคณิตศาสตร์เพราะว่ามัน
เกี่ยวกับตัวเลข
อืเหมือนตอนเนี้ยเราเริ่มบันทึกคลิปตอน
กี่โมงนะคะครูฟ้า
1418 นาทีเออประมาณ 14  1819 นเราก็คิด
แล้วว่าเอ๊เราบันทึก 30
นาทีเราต้องไปหยุดหรือว่าแบบหยุดบันทึก
ตอนกี่โมงเออใช่มั้ยอันนี้ก็คือ
คณิตศาสตร์ใช่มั้ยคะเราก็ต้องบวกไปเป็น
14:49 นใช่ใช่แบบนั้นเลยอันนี้แล้วก็
เวลาที่แบบเฮ้ยตอนนี้ตอนนี้แบบเราบันทึก
คลิปไปแล้วมันเหลือเวลาอีกกี่นาทีอือืใช่
อันนี้ก็ต้องเขียนอ๋อต้องลบหรือเปล่าใช่
ต้องเอาต้องเอา
ใบ
14  49 มาลบ
1439 หรือเปล่าใช่มั้ยคะนั่นน่ะสิถูก
ต้องแล้วค่ะจะเหลือประมาณอีกแค่ 10 นาที
ใช่เหลืออีกแค่ 10 นาทีหรือว่าแบบเวลาที่
เรียมประชุมกับเพื่อนในซมนะครูฟ้าค่ะ
ประชุมกับเพื่อนใน Zoom แล้วมีเวลา 5
นาทีอแล้วเราต้องพูดพูดกัน 3 คนอืคนที่ 1
พูดคนที่ 2 พูดคนที่ 3 พูดมีเวลา 5 นาที
อืครูฟ้าคิดว่าเราแบบต้องใช้คณิตศาสตร์
มั้ยใช้ค่ะ
เป็นอะไรที่ครูฟ้าปวดหัวมากนะคะแต่มันก็
ต้องใช้คณิตศาสตร์ใช่มยบางทีเนี่ยเราอาจ
จะมีเครื่องคิดเลขก็ได้เครื่องคิดเลขก็
คืออันนี้นะคะนัก
เรียนเครื่องคิดเลขใช่ไหมมแต่บางทีเราก็
ต้องรู้ว่าเราต้องใช้บวกลบคูณหรือว่าหาร
เราต้องรู้ใช่ไหมว่าเราใช้ยังไงใช่นี่ก็
คือ
คณิตศาสต์ใช่ถ้าเกิดเกิดมาให้แบบบวกตัว
เลขแบบเยอะๆเยอะๆเราก็คิดว่าออใช้เวลาคิด
นานก็เลยแบบไปกดเครื่องคิดเลขในโทรศัพท์
ใช่มยใช่แต่ว่าจะกดในโทรศัพท์ก็ต้องรู้
ว่าอันนี้จะใช้บวกต้องลบคูณหรือว่าหารใช่
จริงๆคณิตเนี่ยมันก็เป็นสิ่งที่ใช้เยอะ
เหมือนกันนะคะใช้ในชีวิตของเราเนี่ยเยอะ
ใช้ทุกวันใช้ในทุกๆเรื่องใช่มั้ยอืให้กู
เรียนคทุกุเรื่องนะเออตื่นขึ้นมาก็เป็น
ตัวเลขแล้วอ่ะครูฟ้ายังไงอ่ะครูเรียมตื่น
ขึ้นมาก็แบบ 18:00 นดูนาฬิกาใช่มั้ย 18:00
นทำงานกินเวลาอีก 15 นาทีจะต้องแบบล้าง
หน้าแล้วก็ไปออกกำลังกายนะก็เป็นตัวเลข
แล้วอ่ะครูฟ้าใช่เป็นตัวเลขแล้วนะคะถึง
บอกว่าคณิตศาสตร์ที่เราเรียนมาเราก็ต้อง
ใช้ใช่มใช้ทุกวันเอ่า
ใช้ทุกเรื่องนะคะแบบว่ากินข้าวบางทีก็จะ
มีคณิตศาสตร์เพราะว่าคิดราคาข้าวออกไป
ซื้อของใช่ไหมดูเวลาหรือว่าอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยอืใช่จริงๆแล้วครูฟ้าค่ะครูเริมขนาด
ิมิมก็จำได้นะว่าตื่นเช้าเช้าขึ้นมาใช่
มั้ยดูนาฬิกาเข้าไปในห้องน้ำไปแปลงฟันไป
แปลงฟันแบบิมก็บีบบีบยาสีฟันใส่แปรงสีฟัน
นะแล้วก็แบบเฮ้ยยาสีฟันหมดแล้วแล้วเรียม
ก็คิดนะอันที่เรียมซื้อยาสีฟันมาไว้เอ๊
เหลือกี่หลอดน้าอใช่มั้ยมันก็มีตัวเลข
แล้วอ่ะู้ยาสีฟันหมดแล้วเป็นศูนแล้วตอน
นี้อือต้องออกไปซื้อจะซื้อกี่หลอด 1 หลอด
หรือ 2 หลอดอืก็เป็นตัวเลขใช่ 2 หลอดกี่
บาทอืโหมีอะไรอีกหรอที่ไม่เป็นตัว
เลขมี
มยส่วนใหญ่ก็ใช้คณิตนะคะใช้คณิตศาสตร์มี
ตัวเลขในชีวิตของเราอยู่แล้วแต่ว่าช่วง
นี้เนี่ยเราอาจจะไม่รู้เพราะว่ามันสบาย
มากขึ้นใช่มยอย่างครูฟ้าเนี่ยูฟ้าก็
จะสั่งอาหารในแบนะคะพอสั่งอาหารใน Grab
ฟู้ดเนี่ยนักเรียนเวลาเราจะกินอะไรเราก็
กดใช่ไหมถ้าเราจะกินเราก็กดใส่ตะกร้าเรา
กินก็กดใส่ตะกร้านะคะแล้วพอจ่ายเงินเนี่ย
เค้าก็คิดราคาออกมาเรียบร้อย
อ๋อราคาให้เลยนะคะแบบ
ว่าเราไม่ต้อง
คิดเราไม่ต้องคิดเองไงฟ้าก็เลยเอ๊ทำไมตอน
นี้มันสบายมากขึ้นจริงๆมันไม่ค่อยดีนะมัน
ทำให้เราไม่ได้คิดเลยนะคะไม่ค่อยได้คิด
เลยนะคะเกี่ยวกับคณิตศาสตร์อ่ะว่าสังแบ
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวครูฟ้าก็สั่งแบใช่มยครูฟ้า
จะช้อปปิ้งูฟ้าก็เข้าเอ่อช้อปี้
Lazada เป็นแอปพลิเคชันนเรียนอืแล้วอยาก
ได้อะไรอยากได้เสื้ออยากได้กางเกงอยากได้
แชมพูก็กดๆๆแล้วเก็จะบวกบวๆบวมาให้ใช่
เสร็จูพาก็กดจ่าย
เงินใช่เราก็ได้คิดนิดหน่อยว่าอ๋อเงินใน
บัญชีมันมันพอจ่ายอันนี้มั้ยสิ่งที่คิดนะ
ว่าแบบสั่งของราคา 500 โอ้มีเงินในบัญชี
600 อ้อพอๆๆพอมั้ยเออพอแล้วก็คิดเอ๊จะมี
เงินกินข้าวมย
[เพลง]
น้าใช่มั้ยคะครูฟ้าใช่ค่ะมีการคิดเยอะนะ
คะมันก็ถ้าคิดเยอะๆก็ดีแหละอืเพราะครูฟ้า
คิดว่าคณิตศาสตร์มันก็ดีใช่ไหมมเราได้ใช้
จริงๆนะคะถึงเราจะไม่ได้ใช้ Square  RO  P
R บางคนก็อาจจะใช้นะคะแต่ว่าคนทำเราแบบ
ไม่ได้ทำงานอะไรที่มันต้องคิดเกี่ยวกับ
คณิตศาสตร์มากๆเราก็ใช้บวกลบคูณหารก็พอ
แล้วอืใช่ค่ะแค่นั้นถ้าเกิดหาแบบกี่
เปอร์เซ็นต์แบบเนี้ยเรียมก็กดกดเครื่อง
คิดเลขในโทรศัพท์นะกี่เปอร์เซ็นต์เป็น
เปอร์เซ็นต์นี่คือเริ่มกดเครื่องคิดเลขดี
กว่านะปวดหัวใช่ก็ก็เริ่มมาตั้งแต่บวก
แล้วแหละกดเครื่องคิดเลขใช่ใช่เข้า
เครื่องคิดเลขอย่างเดียวเลยนะคะูฟ้าไม่
ค่อยชอบคณิตศาสตร์นะคะนักเรียนไม่ชอบแต่
ไม่ชอบเลยแต่ก็แปลกนะใช่เรียมก็คิดว่าโอ
คณิตศาสตร์ยากคณิตศาสตร์แบบหมันยากไม่
อยากทำอะไรเกี่ยวกับคณิตศาสตร์เลยแต่เอา
จริงๆเราใช้ทุกวันเลยคณิตศาสตร์จริงจริงป
ทุกวันเลยนะคะมันจริงๆมันมีเทคนิคในการ
คิดเร็วๆอยู่ด้วยนะแต่ครูพ้าไม่รู้ไม่ได้
เรียนมาแต่เคยเห็นเด็กๆที่เขาเรียนน่ะใน
เด็กๆตอนนี้นะคะเคเรียนตั้งแต่เด็กๆเลยนะ
เด็กๆจะแบบบวกบวบลบคูณหารเร็วมากๆบางที
แค่พูดแล้วเด็กๆได้ยินเ็ๆเจะบวกๆๆคิดๆ
แล้วก็บอกได้เลยอ่ะคือเร็วมากใช่ๆแบบนั้น
เลยนะคะครูฟ้าว่ามันเป็นเรื่องที่ดีนะอื
ดีเป็นเรื่องที่ดีเหมือนตอนเด็กๆที่ที่
เราเรียนแบบสูตรคูณไงครูฟ้าอืๆแต่เราก็
เรียนแบบท่องเ่ะ 2  *  1 เป็น 2  2  *  2
เป็น 4
อืส่วนคูณคือคูณนะคะนักเรียน 2  *  2
เท่าไหร่ 2  *  3  2  *  4  2  *  5 เด็ก
ไทยเรียนแบบนี้แหละอืก็คือจำจำแบบจำแบบจำ
จนแบบพูดออกมาได้ 1  *  1  *  2  2  2  *
2  4  3  *  2  6  3  *  4  8 แบบเนี้ย
แต่มันจะมี 1 ถึง 12 เนาะว่าคูณกับเลข
อะไรบ้างแต่พอแบบ 13  13  *  2 อได้เท่า
ไหร่วะไม่เคยท่องดู้และอืก็เลยมเทคนิคมัน
ก็ไม่เหมือนกันในแต่ละ Generation ใช่
มั้ยคะแต่ครูคิดว่าคณิตศาสตร์ถ้าเกิดเรา
เรียนใช่มยเราตั้งใจเรียนๆเนี่ยมันก็เอา
มาใช้ในชีวิตประจำวันของเราได้เอามาใช้ใน
ทุกๆวันได้นะคะแล้วก็ดีด้วยบางทีเราคิด
คิดิดเร็วๆอย่างเงี้ยมันก็โอเคไงเพราะว่า
ใช่ครูฟ้าไม่เก่งนะคะครูฟ้ายังต้องใช้
เครื่องคิดเลขอยู่ก็เลยคิดว่าถ้าเราเก่ง
คณิตก็น่าจะดีเหมือนกันอืมจะได้คิดอะไร
เร็วๆได้ใช่มออใช่แต่ว่าบางทีตัวเลขมัน
ซับซ้อนไงตอนเด็กๆเราก็แบบคิดได้นะคิดแบบ
เร็วคิดแบบเร็วพอโตขึ้นมาก็เริ่มแบบสบาย
เครื่องคิดเลขมาเอาเครื่องคิดเลขมากดกด
แล้วก็แบบให้คิดในหัวตอนนี้ก็เลยแบบโอย
ยาก
จังใช่ยากจังมีเครื่องคิดเลขมยคะกลัวทำ
ผิดแบบเยมันก็ยากเหมือนกันนะคะนักเรียน
วันนี้ก็เลยเป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับ
คณิตศาสตร์นะคะที่เอามาใช้ในชีวิตทุกๆวัน
ของทุกคนอืใช่แล้วนักเรียนคิดว่าจริงมที่
เราได้ใช้คณิตศาสตร์ทุกวันเราใช้กับ
เรื่องอะไรบ้างเรียนคิดว่าเยอะเลยนะแต่
เราไม่เคยนึกถึงว่าเรากำลังใช้คณิตศาสตร์
อยู่อืถูกต้องแล้วค่ะแต่ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ย
หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะคิดว่าเดี๋ยวเราเจอกัน
ใหม่วดีโอหน้าใช่ค่ะวดีโอนี้ต้องลาไปก่อน
แล้วค่ะครูฟ้าได้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียนนัก
เรียนสัสดีควดีค่ะ 14:49 แล้วค่ะครบ 30
นาทีแล้วค่ะใช่บ๊ายบายบ๊ายบาย